Clips eight straight As we are standing
by with James Harden Ariana to take it
away James what an amazing performance
tonight 35 points nine assists I saw
that little snow angel impression after
your four-point play there on the ground
how does it feel to get this road win
and go off uh we're playing very very
well right now so just Contin continue
to be consistent on what we do uh take
an approach every every game is a new
challenge for us as a unit and uh you
know tonight was another another night
for us this does make St eight straight
wins for the team what does that say
about how well you guys are jelling and
the potential you guys have we're
figuring it out you know I mean we're
figuring it out we're coming together
we're we're our chemistry is building
game by game uh we still got a long way
to go but you know I mean we're we're
definitely heading in the right
direction there def go ahead defensively
you guys were able to hold Tyrese
halberton to eight points tonight what
do you guys need to carry over to get it
done in Dallas we know how effective he
is uh you know me generating points for
his teammates so you know it was really
really crucial for us to from the
beginning of the game be on him and and
make sure he don't get anything easy um
and so we just had four quarters and we
had a great outcome all right thank you
great
job snow angels all around James
Harden